[THEME MUSIC]
EMMA SERLIN: So
today, the idea--
I'm going to tell
you a little bit
about the origins of
London Speech Workshop,
and also, the method.
So we've got quite
a unique method
that we use with clients.
I'm going to tell you a little
bit about how it came to be.
And then what you
see here is a sample
of some of the kind of
work we do with clients.
There's some tools that we
use-- a whole load of tools.
So we're going to give you
one real concrete tool today,
and we'll work
through, and probably
ask for a bit of
audience participation,
and actually, one
volunteer as well.
And then, the rest of
the time is all about
asking us questions.
So any little communication,
niggle, or conundrum, or just
I'd really like another tool for
that, anything from meetings,
to arguments, to getting
irritated by your boss
and you don't know
how to deal with it,
just throw it at us, because
that's the really fun stuff.
So you've got lots
of time for that.
And this is, obviously,
Jamie, and I'm [INAUDIBLE]
JAMIE CHAPMAN: Hello.
EMMA SERLIN: Hello.
So to begin, I set up London
Speech Workshop nine years ago.
I was actually working as
a TV producer at the time,
and realized I was
going to need some cash.
I was designing all
these drama series ideas,
and I put up three
ads on Gumtree.
It started totally by
accident, is the idea.
So I put three ads up on
Gumtree and thought, what
are the three things I can do?
And bought domain named London
Speech Workshop, London Script
Workshop, and London
Acting Workshops.
And not much creativity
went into it.
And London Speech Workshop
was the one that took off.
And I found myself with lots
of accent softening clients.
So non-native
English speakers who
were wanting to feel more
confident communicating
in English.
And when I began, it
was really generic,
and I was doing
stuff out of a burk.
It wasn't very creative.
And I honestly was wondering--
I had a philosophy degree, and
I'd won an award as a theater
director, and I was like what
am I doing telling people
where to put their
tongues in their mouths,
like this is weird.
And then one day it all changed.
Literally in a eureka moment.
I had a client called Damien.
He was French and successful.
We were sitting there
and I was saying to him,
you need to be able to find
yourself in these words.
You need to sort of
put yourself here.
And then I said, you know
what, why are you doing this?
You've got a lovely accent.
There's loads of
wonderful connotations
with the gorgeous French accent.
You're married to
an Englishwoman.
You're really successful.
And he said to me, that's
exactly the problem.
I can't find myself
in these words.
And then I realized
that actually it
was so much deeper and more
profound than I had got before.
But for many people, the
accent represented a blockage
to them being able to be fully
themselves in the language.
So they were unable
to fully share
in a congruent way, the
ideas, the inspirations,
or their personality, through
that language, through English.
And I realized
something else which
was that I could really help.
And it was actually the nexus of
loads of my interest and loads
of my passions from theater
directing to psychology--
I was doing a psychology
master's at the time.
I started to create different
tools that kind of unlocked
the language for each
individual that I worked with.
And we're going to give you
an example of that in a bit.
But one of the first tools that
I created, and this was all
through seeing issues
come up with the clients.
The first one was
realizing that vowels,
so that space between
two consonants.
For non-native speakers
there's often an issue
with getting a length right.
So is it shorter, is it
long, so ship or sheep,
which can lead to
some challenges.
And then what I realized was
it's not just about going long.
Short-long is the generic,
silly, tedious way of doing it.
It's actually about
an opportunity
to show your feelings.
So a vowel is a space
to put your feelings in.
And being able to
share a tool like
that with a client
just suddenly opens it
up, because you're
not telling them
this is the right way to do it.
You're saying, this is a way
to release what you really
feel into a word.
So it's kind of bang-on
connected to my theatre
directing days.
So from there I got interviewed
by the "Times" newspaper
around the royal
wedding, so to look
at Kate Middleton's speech.
And as a result of
the double-page spread
in the "Times," and
as a result of that,
I'd be getting lots of
native English speakers
who came with all
sorts of things.
But essentially thought
they wanted elocution.
And there was
absolutely no way I
was going to give them
something straightforward,
straightforward elocution,
because I didn't believe in it.
It's not just an accent.
This is so much bigger.
It's communication.
And so I started to
develop more and more tools
to do with facial
expression or eye contact.
Simple little [INAUDIBLE]
in to releasing people
so that they could find
themselves in the language,
essentially.
So after a few
years, all of that--
I decided to put all the
effective communication
stuff into a book.
And I did a bigger, longer book,
and then shrunk it down to size
to a quarter of its
size into this books.
So this is what is in this
book, which many of you
have a nice copy of.
So hopefully you'll enjoy that.
And then there's lots of
other stuff about conflict
and meetings and
all sorts of tools.
So that's kind of the origin.
Since then, we've been
working for nine years,
and Jamie is very much
on the front line working
with hundreds of clients who
are kind of addicted to him.
Seriously.
They come back
and back and back.
JAMIE CHAPMAN: No offense
[INAUDIBLE] to me.
[INAUDIBLE]
EMMA SERLIN: So
on that note, I'm
going to pass you over to Jamie.
He's going to give
you some examples
of how some of these tools
have worked with some clients.
And then we're going
to do some practical.
Thank you.
JAMIE CHAPMAN: Lovely.
Well, you will also
be addicted to me
by the end of today,
one hopes, otherwise,
I shall consider it
a complete failure.
One thing I want to
add, just as somebody
who works with people
almost every day,
really, is in terms
of communication--
and I don't know how many
people here also feel this--
it ought to be the nicest,
best thing about being human,
did it not.
Surely, what sets us apart
is our ability, potentially
at least, to communicate in an
extremely sophisticated way.
And yet, I work with people
day after day, not just
non-native speakers, but
English people as well,
who are torturing themselves
about communication.
So for instance, I was doing
a huge workshop two days ago,
and this great strapping exec
chap who literally said to me,
he gets a rush of adrenaline
when somebody asks
him a question in a meeting.
And has three sleepless nights
before giving a presentation.
That has to stop.
Chat is fun, and
I simply adore it.
And what we're going to look
out today-- no, I really do.
I really love chatting.
And the point is I want
everyone else to love it, too.
And the key thing is
what we have here is,
in a sense, tools,
but also a sort
of formula for how to make
sure, if you do this and this,
you end up with this.
Because too often
for communication,
it's a bit like spinning
the roulette wheel,
and sometimes you go I
was really good today.
And then you spin the
roulette wheel and you go,
no, that didn't
work at all today.
Just did the stars
weren't aligned.
And it's about saying a formula.
If you do one, two, and
three, you end up with four.
And that's what we're going
to look at in just a moment,
I believe, Miss Em.
EMMA SERLIN: Great.
Yes.
Thank you.
So we're going to start with
this is called the intonation
technique, and it's a
three-step technique.
It works with, so if you've
got a prepared presentation,
this works really, really well.
So we're going to share it
so that we can all do it.
So Jamie's going to begin.
JAMIE CHAPMAN: I can.
Now, the first thing is I
never do anything technical.
I need to appoint a
willing volunteer who
would like to-- this is as
far as audience participation
effort goes in this.
I promise.
And it is just weeding out this.
So can we have a
volunteer, please?
EMMA SERLIN: Just
to read [INAUDIBLE]..
But you'll read it at the end.
JAMIE CHAPMAN: Do I have to
pick a willing volunteer?
Do I?
EMMA SERLIN: Oh yay!
Brilliant.
Will you come forward.
JAMIE CHAPMAN: Hurray.
EMMA SERLIN: For
this, it's actually,
you read it out badly,
like the worse, the better.
Because at the end,
you're going to read it
out again using the tools.
So no stress whatsoever.
OK, so I'm going to record you.
Would you be able to come here?
That would be--
Sorry.
Is that all right?
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
Yay.
[INAUDIBLE] So I
just need to find--
there we go.
Voice memos.
OK.
And what's your name?
YOSH: My name's Yosh.
EMMA SERLIN: Yosh,
lovely to meet you.
OK, so here we go.
We're just going to--
I'm going to press
record in a minute,
and I'd just like you to
read this, all the way
to the bottom.
Don't worry about it being good,
just any which way is fine, OK?
YOSH: Yeah.
EMMA SERLIN: Here we go.
YOSH: I feel that this award
was not made to me as a man,
but to my work--
a life's work in agony and
sweat of the human spirit.
Not for glory, and least of all,
for profit, but to create out
of the materials of the
human spirit, something
which did not exist before.
EMMA SERLIN: Lovely.
Round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
Excellent.
Thank you so much.
So we're going to call
on you again at the end.
But if, for now, if you want
to take your seat again.
That was amazing.
Thank you.
OK.
JAMIE CHAPMAN:
Thank you very much.
Now, very, very basically
in terms of communication,
let's define our terms.
All communication is
ever was or ever will
be, is simply the effort to
get what's in here in there
in the best possible way.
And quite often,
it's when that stops
being the aim of the game,
when it turns into some ghastly
test of yourself, an
exam that you fail,
that it all goes
down the toilet.
So this is the key thing.
And if you remember nothing
else from today, what I'd
love you to remember is this.
The task of a good
speaker is to do as much
of the listener's work for
them as you possibly can.
And that starts with
knowing how words work.
Emma's already just
touched on this.
Words are, after all, the
currency of our communication,
aren't they?
Words are made up
of what, chaps?
AUDIENCE: Sounds.
JAMIE CHAPMAN: Sounds, hurrah.
And two key kinds of sound
in particular, vowel sounds
and consonant sounds.
And the first thing is you need
to know what they do for you.
Now, somebody very
wise once said,
and I love this quote,
that vowels are a space
to put your feelings in.
And the way you get all
the color, the feeling,
the meaning in a word.
Now, I can demonstrate this
better than I can describe it.
If I say to you,
I want to go home,
or if I say I want to go home.
What, obviously, conveys
more feeling to you?
Would you try, please, for me
just saying, I want to go home.
AUDIENCE: I want to go home.
JAMIE CHAPMAN: Exactly.
[LAUGH] Now, the
key thing is you
know when you listen to
a speaker and you think,
I love their voice.
They're so expressive.
I like listening to them.
That's not magic.
Mother nature did not
just sprinkle fairy
dust over that crib
when they were little.
This is simply how they're
using their vowel sounds.
David Attenborough's a master.
Have a listen.
Now, consonants are different.
If vowels are about
color, feeling, meaning,
consonants are about
precision and clarity.
They're about efficiency and
respect for the language.
They're a bit like if you
see a tower block being built
and you see the steel
frame go up first,
those are your consonants.
They keep everything in
place and clearly delineated.
Now, there's a
three-step formula
that we look at for
intonation, i.e.,
if you're doing these
things it will sound good.
Number one is emphasis.
And this is the idea that when
we speak, not every word we say
is of the same value.
So some words are of
much greater value
to your listener than others.
And I would say it's a bit
like a highlighter pen.
Now, I'm old enough
to still not really
be able to read off a screen.
I have to print it out and
read it in front, like this.
And whenever I'm
looking at something
and I know I have
to come back to it,
I just highlight the
key words and phrases.
And that's exactly
what you need to always
be doing with your voice.
It's like you have a
highlighter pen in your voice.
And you're highlighting all of
the keywords for your listener,
and the words that
you highlight are
words that contain information.
I'm doing it with my voice now
in rather an exaggerated way.
[LAUGHTER]
So these are the words.
If you were popping
them into a car,
these are the ones in a
sentence-- all the words
in a sentence-- you
have to put some words
in the front seat and some
words in the back seat.
Now, here we are.
If we take each phrase,
let's underline the words
we would want to put
in the front seat.
Now, I will do the first one.
I feel-- I think that's
a jolly important word--
that this award.
Next one is 'was not
made to me as a man.'
Suggestions from
the floor, please.
What shall we underline?
AUDIENCE: Not.
JAMIE CHAPMAN: Not.
Yes, negatives are
always important.
AUDIENCE: Man.
JAMIE CHAPMAN: Man, marvelous.
Next one, 'but to my work.'
AUDIENCE: Life's work.
JAMIE CHAPMAN: Lovely.
A life's work.
AUDIENCE: Life's.
JAMIE CHAPMAN: Splendid.
And this is absolutely
critical here,
because what you're especially
telling us is new information.
We already know it's your work.
It's your life's work.
Imagine how
ridiculous it would be
if you went to see Daniel Craig
in his latest incarnation,
and he said, the name's
Bond, James Bond.
You'd say, well, yes, I know.
He has to emphasize James.
[LAUGHTER]
Lovely.
Life's work.
Now, here's a long one. 'In the
agony and sweat of the human
spirit.'
What shall we have, chaps?
AUDIENCE: Agony.
JAMIE CHAPMAN: Agony.
AUDIENCE: And sweat.
JAMIE CHAPMAN: Marvelous.
AUDIENCE: Human spirit.
JAMIE CHAPMAN: Splendid.
Excellent.
What should we have
in this next bit?
AUDIENCE: Not.
JAMIE CHAPMAN: Not, negatives.
Yes.
Glory.
'And least of all, for profit.
What do we fancy here?
AUDIENCE: Least.
JAMIE CHAPMAN: Least.
Profits, marvelous.
'But to create out of the
materials of the human spirit.
What should we have here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Create.
JAMIE CHAPMAN: Create.
Materials, yes.
And what should we have here?
I think this one's
fairly obvious, yes.
And 'something which
did not exist before.'
AUDIENCE: Not.
JAMIE CHAPMAN: Not.
Exist.
Yes, I suppose we
could have that.
Now, let's have a listen.
Now, just to prove my point
about how some words are
of much greater value to
your listener than others,
just close your
eyes for a moment,
and I'm going to
read you just the 2/3
to a half with the words
that we haven't underlined.
If that's for me,
tell them I'm busy.
And what I'll do is I'm going
to read those back to you.
And I want you to imagine,
if I gave you some paints,
would you be able to make
any sense of this at all,
and could you paint any picture.
So just the words that
aren't underlined.
I that this was made to me
as a, but to my a work in b,
and of the for and although for.
But two out of thee of thee
something which did before.
What sort of a picture
did you manage to produce?
AUDIENCE: None.
JAMIE CHAPMAN: Very little.
Now, let's have a look.
Again, close eyes, and let's
see what sort of images
we can come up with for the
1/3 to a half with the words
we have underlined.
Here we go.
Feel award, not man, work.
Life's agony,
sweat, human spirit.
Not glory, least profit, create
materials human spirit not
exist.
Can you see how
much clearer that
is in terms of just the
images you can have.
So that's our first top tip.
And now my glamorous assistant
will now tell us the next two
steps on our little odyssey.
EMMA SERLIN: Great.
Thank you.
That was lovely.
JAMIE CHAPMAN: Pleasure.
EMMA SERLIN: So the idea
of this tool as well,
just to add to the
brilliant stuff Jamie said,
is that you can choose.
So it can be every word
that has money or value,
or it can be a selection.
And it's up to you,
but as long as you
are choosing and
consciously placing them
in the head of your
listener or your audience,
that's what starts
to give you control
over the landscape that's
being built in their heads.
So step number two is pauses.
And this is the
idea that we don't
talk in very long
sentences like this,
that start at the
beginning and go to the end
with tabloids of
thoughts in them
and you never stop so no
one can keep track with you.
Like that.
We use pauses and
we speak in units.
So there's a kind
of balanced sense
of taking your
listener by the hand
and walking at a pace that
works for them and for you.
So there's sort of a flow,
like a phrasing in music.
So here we are.
If we take that idea
and put it here--
again, let's do
it with everyone--
finding the first pauses.
And again, it's not absolute.
There's not the
right way to do it.
There's a sense of
feeling it out as well.
So the first pause
I'll do, and then we
can do the rest together.
So I feel that this award.
So we can put one there.
Thank you.
Now my glamorous assistant.
Both very glamorous.
So next one.
I feel that this award.
Who's got an idea where
the next one could be?
AUDIENCE: Man?
EMMA SERLIN: Was not
made to me as a man.
Perfect.
Next one?
AUDIENCE: But to my work.
EMMA SERLIN: But to my work.
Absolutely.
Next one?
AUDIENCE: Life's work.
EMMA SERLIN: A life's work.
Brilliant.
Next one?
AUDIENCE: Agony.
EMMA SERLIN: In the
agony and sweat.
Absolutely.
So we always do full
stops, obviously.
Of the human spirit.
And next?
AUDIENCE: For glory.
EMMA SERLIN: Not for glory.
Perfect.
And least of all, for profit.
Next?
Can people see it?
But to create out of them--
so I'll do the whole thing.
But to create out of the
materials of the human spirit.
So we can probably
divide that up a bit.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
EMMA SERLIN: Yeah, so we have
got some different options
there.
But, create, and materials.
And all of them can work.
That's the thing.
So it's about what you
want to frame and place
in your listener's mind.
So to show you what that would
look like, but, for example,
or but to create, for example.
Or but to create out
of the materials.
So do you see it's about
what you decide to put in.
If you decide to put a
whole lot of words in,
you're reducing the value,
the energy you can give,
to each individual word.
Which means that if you've
got a really important word,
and Barack Obama's, like all
of his inauguration speeches
way back when are really
good to listen to for this.
Because he would say
such important things,
he'd do them in sentences
of two or three words,
and he'd get the impact.
And if you do any more,
if you do complex words
in a sentence of seven words,
people will just get lost.
The brain can't hold on to
it, figure it out, and listen
to the next sentence.
So let's go for create.
Thank you.
So but to create.
And then another one?
AUDIENCE: Spirit.
EMMA SERLIN: Great, spirit.
And then the final one.
I'll read it all out and see
if we want any in between.
Something which did
not exist before.
So we could do that in one.
Do you want any--
AUDIENCE: Something.
EMMA SERLIN: Something, yeah.
We could do something.
Brilliant.
So that's the idea of pausing.
Now, it's not enough
to just pause.
Because if you do just pause
and you don't put anything
in the units-- we call
it justifying the pause.
If you don't justify the fact
that you're putting in a pause,
it can just sound like you're
stopping, starting, stopping,
starting.
So I'll give you an example.
I feel that this award was
not made to me as a man,
but to my work, and life's work.
You can see what I mean, right?
So we actually have
to fill the space
in between those two pauses.
Fill that unit with
something, with some color,
with some intonation.
Now, we call this-- we've
got all these funny phrases
at London Speech
Workshop, and we call
this one a psychological hook.
And the idea is that if you've
got a little puppy on a leash
and it's wandering off, you're
just tugging at the attention.
So that's the attention
of your listener.
So we want a little
hook in each unit
to make sure that
you've got people.
And it's the
difference between me
going Jamie, [SHARPER] Jamie.
And I can tell by that look.
Jamie.
But he's going to perk up.
JAMIE CHAPMAN: He did.
EMMA SERLIN: He did.
So you see I'm doing
something with my voice,
and it's literally
going up and down.
And if we just isolate it as a
sound, I go mmm, like a hook.
So that's what we want
to do within a unit.
So for example here, I
feel that this award.
Rather than I feel
that this award.
So can you hear where
I'm doing it here?
I feel that this award.
And you could also do it there.
But do you see, it's having
a slightly different effect.
Now, that is-- you
don't have to get overly
into the science of it because
it needs to be intuitive.
But when you've got
your presentation,
you'll know what's
really important to me?
What do I really want to
get into my listeners minds?
And that's what you underline.
And actually, Barack
Obama, we didn't train him.
It's a ridiculous thing to say.
But if you look at
one of his speeches,
there's all of these
underlined words.
Like he has annotated his
speech in this kind of way
because it works.
Because if you
know what you want
to get into your listener's
head, it's going to get there.
So it's really nice advice.
So to carry on.
Another point to make is
that if for some reason
you need to buy
yourself some time.
So if you've like let's say
you've got a splurge of ink
on your presentation and
you're trying to figure out
what that word is, or
trying to figure out
what you're going
to say next, you
couldn't overly work one unit.
But if you work it
with intonation,
people will just think,
oh, they really mean that.
So for example, I feel that
this award was not made
to me as a man, but to my work.
So obviously I'm going
really slowly there.
But if you work it, you can
sort of break it open, in a way,
rather than I feel that
this award was not made
to me as a man, but to my work.
Because you guys aren't
going to get that,
and I'm not going to
have any opportunity
to put my feelings or my
vision and what matters to me
into the words if I just
say it really quickly.
So with that in mind, let's
actually-- it's quite fun.
We'll just do a little
bit just with the top row.
And what we'll do
is one unit each.
And so just to get
the idea of a hook.
So I'll start, and
then if you go next
and we go along, if
that's all right with you,
and we'll just enjoy doing--
putting a psychological
hook into each unit.
So I feel--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
EMMA SERLIN: And you
can pass the mic on.
Thank you, Rob.
I feel that this award--
can you see it?
AUDIENCE: Was not made to me.
JAMIE CHAPMAN: Oh.
All the way to--
sorry.
I should have said all the
way to the end of the pause,
but that was brilliant.
AUDIENCE: Was not
made to me as a man.
But to my work, my
life's work in the--
[LAUGHTER]
JAMIE CHAPMAN: So if
you'd carry on from there.
AUDIENCE: Life's work
in the agony and sweat
of the human spirit.
EMMA SERLIN: Good.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Not for glory.
AUDIENCE: And least
of all for profit.
AUDIENCE: But to create
out of the materials
of the human spirit--
AUDIENCE: Which did
not exist before.
EMMA SERLIN: Lovely.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Yosh, would you please
come to the front?
Right.
You ready?
YOSH: I think so.
EMMA SERLIN: Why don't you have
a little practice run and then
we'll record, OK?
YOSH: OK.
EMMA SERLIN: So
what we want to do
is just really enjoy
each unit, and putting
some kind of little
intonation hook in each unit.
And obviously, you put the pause
in each time there's a line.
YOSH: Sure thing.
I feel that this award was
not made to me as a man,
but to my work, a
life's work in the agony
and sweat of the
human spirit, not
for glory, and least
of all, for profit.
EMMA SERLIN: And I'm
going to stop you there,
because this is so good, we
might as well just record.
[APPLAUSE]
Ready?
From the top.
Really good.
OK.
YOSH: I feel that this award
was not made to me as a man,
but to my work, a
life's work in the agony
and sweat of the
human spirit, not
for glory, and least
of all, for profit.
But to create out
of the materials
of the human spirit, something
which did not exist before.
[APPLAUSE]
EMMA SERLIN: Wow.
That was fantastic.
Thank you so much.
That was wonderful.
Let's do-- you do the next bit.
You're going to--
JAMIE CHAPMAN: Oh, yes.
Of course.
So I was enjoying that so much.
Just one tiny thing
I adapt to it.
Key thing I think
often that's missing
when people think
about communication
and they get into that rabbit
in the headlights mode,
is that you end up
reading the news,
rather than telling us a story.
Now, who here has read a story
to a child ever in their lives?
Right.
Now, my nephew, Berty,
is four years old.
Well, he's five now, but
he was four at Christmas.
They are-- you can
corroborate this, I'm sure--
the most merciless critics
in the world, are they not?
Because if they're bored,
they just get up and they go.
No filter.
They are bored.
So when I was reading
Berty's story,
I was trying to keep his
little four-year-old attention
span on the story, and
quite instinctively,
I was emphasizing the
keywords, and upping my energy,
and really trying to use my
voice to paint some pictures,
because otherwise,
he's out of there.
And my discovery, or our
discovery at London Speech
Workshop is just this.
All adults are, are
grown up children.
They will still be bored
and want to leave the room,
but socially and professionally,
they're no longer
entitled to say so or do so.
Now, of course,
I'm not suggesting
that you speak to all of
your colleagues and clients
as if they are four years old,
whether they deserve it or not.
But the principle
remains the same.
Because as adults,
we're still drawn
to speakers who tell us stories,
and that's the key thing.
Now, whenever we listen back,
and we're going to listen back
now I understand, right?
Three questions,
because you must never,
ever slag off the speaker,
because everyone when you hear
yourself, everyone always
just goes, oh, my god,
I can't believe I
sound like that,
can't believe I look like that.
Key thing is you focus
entirely on you as a listener,
and you ask yourself just the
following three questions.
Number one, how much does the
speaker value what he's saying?
Two, how much does the speaker
value me as their listener?
And then finally, does
the speaker make me care?
And that's it.
And I think what
we're going to do
is listen back to
both those recordings
and we'll ask ourselves
those three questions.
You're so much better at
writing on the board than me.
If you notice, look.
Now the other one took me ages,
and it was my second attempt.
There we are.
Lovely.
EMMA SERLIN: I'm going
to write these out
so you can have them at the end.
Yeah, let's do that.
JAMIE CHAPMAN: Yes, let's.
EMMA SERLIN: Thank you.
[RECORDING PLAYBACK]
- I feel that--
I feel that this award was
not made to me as a man,
but to my work, a life's
work in agony and sweat
of the human-- of
the human spirit,
not for glory, and
least of all for profit,
but to create out
of the materials
of the human spirit, something
which did not exist before.
I feel that this award was
not made to me as a man,
but to my work, a
life's work in the agony
and sweat of the human spirit,
not for glory, and least
of all, profit,
but to create out
of the materials of the
human spirit, something
which did not exist before.
[APPLAUSE]
JAMIE CHAPMAN: Yay!
Lovely.
EMMA SERLIN: Great.
JAMIE CHAPMAN: Emma.
EMMA SERLIN: OK.
So the three
questions correspond
with the communication
equation, which
is the name of the first book.
Which is A, for authenticity.
So that is, how
much does a speaker
care about what they're saying.
Are they authentic?
Do they care?
Do they value it?
Two, is C, for connection.
So how much do they care
about their listeners
and their audience?
Now, if A and C are
authenticity and connection,
or I care about what I'm
saying and I care about you,
if that's there, you
get E for engagement,
which is the listener cares.
So let's ask the
audience for listening
to Yosh who was brilliant.
Thank you, again.
So in the first recording,
what do we think?
How much did the speaker
value what they were
saying in the first recording?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
EMMA SERLIN: Not that much.
AUDIENCE: Well,
he didn't really--
it was his first
time reading it I
think so he didn't know
how he felt about it.
EMMA SERLIN: Yeah.
Yeah, and it's-- absolutely.
It's about our
impression as well.
So it's not like Yosh just
didn't care, because actually,
he probably didn't care
that much differently
from either one to the
other, like it was just
a piece of recording.
He was surprised in
front of loads of people.
But it's about our perception.
Because if we feel he
cares, we're going to care.
So good point.
So not very much
at the beginning.
Any ideas of why that was?
What gave us that sense
that the speaker didn't care
very much at the beginning?
AUDIENCE: He was quite
monotone and flat.
EMMA SERLIN: Monotone
and flat, absolutely.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I think it's
a lack of context.
EMMA SERLIN: And
lack of context, OK.
Yeah.
Great.
What about number two?
So did you get the sense that
the speaker cared about you,
the listener, in the first one?
Not really.
It didn't reach out.
Oh, the mic's gone.
Now it's back.
Wow.
And then finally,
so how much did
you care in the first one about
what you were listening to?
Not very much.
And the second one,
how much do you
feel that the speaker cared
about what they were saying?
AUDIENCE: A lot more.
EMMA SERLIN: A lot more.
And what do you think gave
that impression to you?
What was the feeling?
AUDIENCE: Because there's
more passion than words.
EMMA SERLIN: More passion.
Anything else?
There's no right or wrong here.
I'm just curious.
AUDIENCE: More punch.
EMMA SERLIN: More punchy, yeah.
AUDIENCE: More rhythm.
EMMA SERLIN: More rhythm.
AUDIENCE: Emphasis.
EMMA SERLIN: And emphasis.
Yeah.
And actually, all of
that is more energy.
Because when we give our energy
to something, it's our way of--
whatever we do.
It's our breath.
It's the way we show
we value something.
So it's like
actually, this is just
a device for putting
your energy into words.
Brilliant.
So how much did you
feel the speaker
cared about you, the
listener, in the second one.
AUDIENCE: A little more.
EMMA SERLIN: Yeah We
won't go into why,
but there's a general
sense that he cares more.
Good.
And as a result,
honestly, did you,
or did you engage more with
the text in the second one?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
EMMA SERLIN: Yeah, OK.
Good.
Well, that's right answer.
But really, it works.
That's the point.
It's simple steps.
And what you're doing, what
we actually asked you to do,
is very mechanical.
It's just pauses, it's
an intonation hook
with your voice.
You can do it on an
entirely fresh text.
You do not need
to know the text.
The weird thing is you don't
need to know the context--
I think you said context.
But it gives the impression
that you know the context
and that you care.
That's why this works.
Do you got any more
to add on that?
JAMIE CHAPMAN: What I would
say, the key thing for me
is simply that the
second one sounds
like it's being read for me.
So you're reading
this for my benefit,
and it's no longer just a
test of you reading this out.
And that's absolutely vital,
because that immediately
makes me hook into it.
Later on we have
an exercise, when
we're doing non-verbals, which
we won't get to do today,
and we tell a story
two different ways.
Absolutely true.
Done this hundreds of times.
And for every client
it's the same.
I can do the first
one completely blank,
and you'll get nothing.
And then I will tell exactly the
same story, same words exactly,
but this time really engaging
with my voice and physically.
And do you know what
people do every time?
Oh, right, yeah, yeah.
I've just told you this.
And everyone's the same!
But all I'm doing is I'm telling
you, you will engage with this.
I'm going to hook, hook, hook.
It's so powerful, genuinely.
There you are.
That's my input.
EMMA SERLIN: And
that's the thing.
The whole point of all of
these things, like Jamie
said at the beginning,
it's not magic dust.
It's simple techniques of
using our own toolbox, which
is eyes, hands.
I mean, everyone has it.
Like no one's stuck
with a monotone voice,
or a mouth that won't open,
or a tongue that moves--
[DISHES FALLING]
No, that was a great exit.
Even breaking plates.
JAMIE CHAPMAN: I valued
the way you dropped that.
I valued it.
[LAUGHTER]
You know, that's just
what would happen to me.
Bless your heart.
EMMA SERLIN: That's brilliant.
That's a good exit.
So that's a little sample
of the kind of work
that we do, but
hopefully a tool that you
can use for yourselves.
Now, questions.
I open the field to questions.
So really, the
meatier, the better.
Or even, if you're
like, I don't even
know if I can be bothered
to ask this, ask it.
Great.
[LAUGHTER]
EMMA SERLIN: Do you
want to start with this?
JAMIE CHAPMAN: Well, do you
know, that's a jolly good one.
And I tell you why.
It comes right back to here.
Because imagine
you have to discuss
something awfully boring.
And it's just, so you think
I'm not personally, absolutely
delighted with this information.
If you go into
that view, that is
what your listener will feel.
Now, it's still authentic
because there'll
be some part of you in
a work presentation that
thinks I have to get this over.
This is part of my job,
and I value my job,
and this information, dull as
ditchwater though it may be,
will actually,
nevertheless, have
to be conveyed in
an interesting way.
But if you break that
equation, A for authenticity,
I value what I'm saying and
I value you as my listener,
down the toilet.
In fact, you've got
to work doubly as hard
when it's dull as ditchwater.
Because you've
got to think, I've
got to hook you in somehow.
By hook, line, and
sinker, I will get you in.
And that's when the technical
actually really helps.
EMMA SERLIN: And
just to add, that's
where the intonation technique
is really useful, because you
can literally, mark
in your pauses,
mark in literally the key words,
the front seat words, and fake
it.
If we can find our
integrity with it,
so our reason for doing
it, why are we motivated,
what do we value.
And it could be as much
as I'm proud of my team.
If you can find that
brilliant-- sometimes you can't.
But you still want
to engage, you still
have the connect piece.
So it's like finding that.
Because what we're wanting
is in an ideal world
you're going to care, but if you
don't, but you care about them
and you want them to be
engaged, that's enough for you
to put the A in for yourself.
EMMA SERLIN: Very good question.
We've got a whole- that's
session two in our 10 session
course.
But it's a really good question.
Jamie, you start, and
then I'll add as well.
JAMIE CHAPMAN: Sure.
I mean, for me, I
always try and make
it session two
and session three,
because it's a really
important thing.
Because it's a perfectly valid
thing to say, now listen,
[INAUDIBLE],, it's all very well
when you've got this lot here.
Of course it sounds
better the second time
when I've circled bits
and underlined bits
and read it three times.
But how do I get that into
when I'm speaking off the cuff?
Now, without going into an
enormous amount of detail,
each one of these is this unit.
And each one has to be landed
with care and with energy.
So for instance--
I'm going to use a pen.
Excuse me.
I would like to
hand you this biro
and I should like
you to take it.
Now, what feels more
like I value this?
I've got a really good idea.
Or does it feel more
valued when I do this.
I've got a really
good [SOFTLY] idea.
And it simply doesn't land
because you're already often
off the cuff, thinking of the
next thing you have to say.
So we start with this idea
of landing the thought,
so really valuing it.
And the key thing that I notice
when I'm working with people
and getting them from this
into off the cuff speech,
is that they think about their
presentation as like a mountain
that they have to
pole vault over,
and they go, oh my
god, I'm never going
to get over that mountain.
You think, well, no,
you won't in one go.
But it's this one
little step at a time,
and it's the same thing when
you're speaking off the cuff.
It's also really
good when you start
working on speed
of delivery issues
for people who get really,
really fast when they
are presenting, because
they're nervous.
But I won't go onto that
because someone else
may have a question about it.
Thank you very much.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
JAMIE CHAPMAN: Do.
May I have my pen?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
JAMIE CHAPMAN: Thank you.
JAMIE CHAPMAN: In terms of the
work for the listener, yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JAMIE CHAPMAN: Oh, yes, yes.
It was a jolly good question.
You were saying that
one of the things I said
is we have to do the work for
the listener as much as we
possibly, possibly can.
Now, the ways you do that
are actually the ways
we've looked down here.
So number one, I'm
telling you what words
are important to emphasis.
So that does a lot
of the work for you.
So for instance,
if I say to you,
I never said you stole
my hat, I can give you
seven different meanings of
that sentence to emphasis alone.
I never said you stole my hat.
She did.
I never said you stole
my hat, I said he did.
Can you see just through
emphasis you're actually
not only giving your
listener the words,
you're giving them an
interpretation of the words.
That's why this helps.
Next thing, pauses.
So [TALKING FAST]
when we speak, we
don't speak in
big, long sentences
and never come to an
end, because if we did,
it'd be really difficult for
the listener really difficult
to speak, especially
if everything
turns into one long stream of
conscious without a beginning,
middle or end.
I've just made your
life really hard there.
You've managed it, but
you're trying to follow him.
You're going just
about got it, OK.
But you're going to give up on
me after a while of doing that.
So hence, giving you
this in bite-sized chunks
is a bit like spoon
feeding the baby.
Now, once you're spoon
feeding the baby, with one
piece of information at
a time, and telling you
where the key
information is, you
find that just as a
listener, your job
has become a lot easier,
[TALKING FAST] than saying I
want to get this done as
fast as possible and finish.
That makes sense?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JAMIE CHAPMAN: Fabulous.
Sorry, that was a
jolly long answer.
JAMIE CHAPMAN: Oh,
that's a good one.
EMMA SERLIN: So a good technique
for that is coming back
to this idea of delivering.
So that's sort of with the
response of off the cuff.
If you speak in
each unit and you're
thinking about a unit at a
time, and you're delivering it,
then you arrive at a pause,
rather than an oh, my god,
I've got to say loads of things.
I've got this whole long
thought and I've got to it.
And oh, my god, now I'm starting
in the middle of a sentence.
Um, ah, oh.
So it breaks it down.
It's like a ladder.
It's a steady rung by rung.
And in this idea of
delivery, and also
even getting physical with it,
it grounds you in each moment
because you're breaking it down.
Because the mind comes up
with your ums and your ahs
when you feel stranded,
and you're going,
what can I come up with next?
And there's this pressure
to pick an idea that's
in your head somewhere.
Whereas actually, you
don't need to do that,
because you can just
do, oh, I'm here.
I'm present in the
one comment or the one
thought that I have to say now.
And I've delivered it.
Oh, and another one's come.
And giving the message
of that to your brain,
both through your intonation,
so it's kind of landing it.
And through this concept of
connecting and delivering
takes away the pressure,
and it actually
gives you more space to think.
And the other little tip
for that is also the vowels.
So elongating your vowels,
rather than [TALKING FAST]
saying [INAUDIBLE]
really quickly,
and then your thought processes
at the end of the words where
you go um, you can go, and
saying a word really quickly,
and you've just given
yourself thinking time.
EMMA SERLIN: That's an
interesting question.
JAMIE CHAPMAN: That
is a good question.
EMMA SERLIN: I
think I'd probably
need to sit down and
create a new book.
[LAUGHTER]
We've got a lovely little--
one of our tools is based on
a poem called "Jabberwocky",
and I actually created
that with an 11-year-old,
and then was like, this
is great for adults.
But they've got a
different mindset
and a different
attention span, so it's
about gamifying things a lot.
As Jamie said, it's
communicating with an adult.
When you think of
them as a big child,
he's slightly more polite.
And it's a good return,
because with our clients,
we gamify everything.
There's a before and
an after, and it all
becomes very relaxed and fun.
Like we did with
Yosh, rather than we
taught you the technique,
get it right now.
So again, that psychology
of just lighting up, taking
the pressure off is good.
JAMIE CHAPMAN: Do you know,
that's a blooming good one.
I think that's an
excellent question.
Can I just respond to that?
EMMA SERLIN: Sure.
JAMIE CHAPMAN: The key
thing about speaking off
the cuff that I notice is this.
You've got to understand that
when you speak off the cuff,
it's completely different from
when you've written something
down.
And people seem to judge
it by the same criteria,
and judge it jolly harshly.
Now, the USP, the unique selling
point of written communication
is that it is polished,
edited, and logical.
And therefore, you can
come back to it perfect.
You can polish and polish it.
That is not the USP of speaking.
And yet, I watch people give
presentations, and clearly,
what they are attempting to
do is attempting to dictate
the perfect email in one go
and they will punish themselves
if they cannot manage this.
This is unfair.
I absolutely call the ref
because this is not allowed,
because that's not the point.
The USP-- I mean, for instance,
if you sent me an email,
and it had dot, dot, dot,
and abandoned sentences,
and an illogical structure,
and grammatical errors,
I'd think, now, come along.
Read it through before
pressing send, and tidy it up.
But I never think that
when you just speak to me.
Of course I knew
sometimes you'll
struggle to find
that word, and that's
not the end of the world.
Because the USP of
verbal communication
is that it's interactive and
spontaneous and engaging.
That's its USP.
So of course, if
it doesn't come out
in beautifully eloquent
phrases and completely fluent,
that's fine.
That's not really the point.
It just has to engage me
and take me on a journey.
So that's the first thing.
EMMA SERLIN: And I will just--
Brilliant, I agree.
And I will just add to that.
And also, I say ums, too.
Lots of ums.
A really good thing that
I love is owning it.
Owning that space where
you're looking for the word.
Because it's your word,
and it's your idea,
and it's your perfectly formed.
It's going to be.
The apple's going to drop
from the tree and land.
And so giving it.
Rather than going oh,
white headlights, panic,
and a rabbit in the headlights,
I can't think of the word.
It can be this
wonderful pregnant pause
of finding that word.
And I remember an example.
When I worked as a
theatre director,
I remember I would get a
moment where I'd be like, oh,
there's something here.
And I remember having
a rehearsal process,
and then going stop, stop.
There's something here.
And then my mind went blank.
And I was like, this is funny.
Everyone's watching
me going, what's
she going to come up
with, this wonderful bit
of creative vision.
And I was just like, [STARING].
And then, because I
could, I just sat in it.
And after about five seconds,
the idea started to come in,
and I delivered it.
Now, if I had panicked
at that blank,
and it was total blankness
for those five seconds.
But if I panicked,
as we can easily
do under the pressure
of a conversation,
nothing would have
happened, and I
would have lost status
in the room, or whatever.
So it's about enjoying
that moment of just going,
it's going to land
and trusting it.
And it's your vision.
So even if it's not the word
that a native English speaker
would use, it's yours.
JAMIE CHAPMAN: It's the thought
that happens during the pause.
I can only say the thought
that happens for me.
I always think for me, if
I can't think of the word,
the thought in my head
has to be no, just let me
find the perfect word.
Not just any word,
because you're worth more.
As opposed to [SINGING] da
da, dun, da, dun, dun, duh.
I'm a bad communicator. da-da,
da, da, da-da-da-da fail.
Get rid of that.
That helps absolutely nobody.
Good.
EMMA SERLIN: We have, I
think, six minutes left.
So if there's any
more questions,
you've got six minutes.
EMMA SERLIN: I would say working
out which bits of the story--
It's not about
doubling your speed.
Because as we know, if
you don't put anything--
if you don't get it
into their heads,
they're going to
walk away going,
well, that's six
minutes that's wasted.
So actually, it's about you
going, what are the key points,
and being in there enjoying it.
And we haven't really been able
to talk about it much today,
but one of our metaphors is
about creating a landscape
in your listener's head.
So you can engage physically.
You can sort of this is over
here, and that idea's there,
and then we've got
sort of this here.
So by doing that,
by moving around,
you can actually imprint
the different ideas.
And you might be like
there's three salient points,
and just, I want to land there.
Get those points
in, rather than--
JAMIE CHAPMAN: Yeah.
Excessive speed never works.
It's a huge misnomer about, say,
I've got a lot of information.
I know.
I'll say it really fast.
It does no good.
Because go back to the
very first thing we said.
The whole point is getting
information from here
[POINTING TO HEAD],, in there
[POINTING TO AUDIENCE]..
Not getting information
from here, out.
Because if that were the
case, speaking quickly
would be a wonderfully effective
way of doing it, but it's not.
It's not.
Oh, yes.
JAMIE CHAPMAN: Good one.
Good one.
Emma, you'd be better for this.
[LAUGHTER]
EMMA SERLIN: So
I'm actually really
passionate about this stuff.
I did training in San
Francisco called non-violent
communication, and it's--
[LAUGHTER]
It does what it says
and is beautiful.
Like really, really beautiful.
And it's based on this
work from this therapist,
and Carl Rogers,
and then someone
called Harvey
Rosenberg created it.
And there are some
ideas from that.
This is actually all
in the book as well.
So step one is knowing
about breathing.
So your first
reaction, that heat
when we get when something
happens that gets us mad,
is the part of our brain
that is basically very basic.
It's animal.
And that's where it goes to.
It's like our amygdala.
If we wait, because it
takes about five seconds
to move into your
cortex, so to move
into the sophisticated
part where you can go OK,
let's figure this
out, what's going on.
So you just have to wait.
First thing, wait five seconds.
And if you can breathe
during those five seconds,
even better.
Rather than I'll
wait five seconds.
So you breathe out.
And then when that five
seconds have passed,
a really good tip from
non-violent communication
is trying to figure out
what's going on for them.
And then figuring out
what's going on for you.
So one of the lines in it is
be an advocate of your own,
and the other person's, values.
So if they're mad at you
because they're like,
this is late again, and I've had
enough, and what are you doing?
Are you doing this
to wind me up?
And your reaction is [ANGRY]
no, it's not all about you.
I've got this, this
and this deadline,
which you asked me
for, or whatever.
So you breathe.
And then it's like, right,
what is going on for them?
Like actually, is this
because their value
is I have to get things
on time for my senior boss
and it puts me into a panic if
I don't get what I've asked for,
or is it stress at
home, or whatever.
So just that process of asking,
and not necessarily getting
to the right answers, gets you
into a place towards empathy,
towards compassion.
And also towards these feelings
and this heat may not actually
be the whole story.
And once you're at
that, it's so much
easier to be able to ask them
a question, or to go, OK,
and what was going on for me?
Like actually this heat is
because I'm working really hard
and I don't feel I'm getting
the recognition I want.
Well, that's actually
something else.
That's from-- you know.
So you can start to
separate, take the heat out.
And then from that place,
it's communication.
And questions are so powerful.
So it might just be, depending
on what the situation is,
it might be I'm not
sure I understood
before how important this was.
But can you just explain
to me this and this
just so I get it, or is
it because this and this.
So it's just that gentle
digging can just take--
also, if they've come
to you with anger,
can just take the wind
out of their angry sails.
AUDIENCE: With that,
please [INAUDIBLE]..
[APPLAUSE]